[Music]  this is the Oasis it's a place where the  limits of reality are your own  imagination  people come to the Oasis for all the  things they can do but they stay because  of all the things they can be a mere  talking to all of you now because our  future is being threatened I just came  here to escape but I found something  much bigger than myself I found my  friends  [Music]  people have lost their lives  [Music]  this is war wrecking taller the tapes of  find him  welcome to the rebellion wait  [Music]  you don't tell anyone who you are you  can't use your real name  hold on to something  this isn't just again  no absolute life-and-death stuff  [Music]  are you willing to fight  [Music]  come with me  [Music]